und ein Flugzeugabsturz am Ätna in
Italien der beschäftigt uns jetzt dort
wo es derzeit wieder Waldbrände gibt
dort ist jetzt nämlich ein Löschflugzeug
gecrasht
sie wollten Menschen retten jetzt sind
sie selbst gestorben im Einsatz
auf Sizilien bricht ein Löschflugzeug
der Feuerwehr zu einem Einsatz am Vulkan
Ätna auf die Maschine wirft gerade
Wasser über einem Waldbrand ab als es
einen Bergrücken streift explodiert und
abstürzt die zwei Piloten haben keine
Chance
die Unfallursache zunächst unklar
möglicherweise ein technischer Defekt
Siziliens regionalpräsident Renate
schifani drückte den Angehörigen der
Piloten sein Beileid aus
bei der Unglücksmaschine handelt es sich
um eine sogenannte Kanada call 415 sie
waren in Löscharbeiten eines Waldbrandes
beteiligt der am Abend vorher
ausgebrochen war
[Musik]